l'administration trempe annoncent un
assouplissement majeur de l'encadrement
des émissions de méthane c'est le
deuxième plus grand émetteur de gaz à
effet de serre après le dioxyde de
carbone lagence de la protection de
l'environnement va annuler l'obligation
pour les pétrolières et les gazières
d'inspecter et de colmater les fuites
dans les puits les pipelines les
entrepôts on en parle avec alain webster
professeur au département d'économique
de l'école des sciences de la gestion à
l'université de sherbrooke bonsoir
monsieur webster bonsoir
alors cette règle là sur le méthane
était en place depuis 2007 sous barack
obama pourquoi à béton imposer cette
règle en 2016 on est à peine un an après
l'accord de paris l'a donc le canada les
etats-unis cherchent les meilleures
façons de mettre en oeuvre des
stratégies de réduction des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre et donc en 2016
accor canada-états-unis volonté
simultanée de réduire les émissions de
méthane de 45 % d'ici 2025 accord à
laquelle s'est joint le mexique quelques
mois plus tard donc c'est pas ça mc une
stratégie des états unis c'est tout si
une stratégie nord-américaine et ça sera
fort intéressant d'entendre le premier
ministre de l'alberta où les chefs des
différents partis politiques n'ayant
nous parler de leurs stratégies de
réduction de méthane dans les prochains
mois si les américains se retirer cette
approche plutôt que nous parler de
péréquation et de pipelines
mais l'administration dit en outre passe
nos compétences comme gouvernement
fédéral et on n'a pas besoin de faire ça
de toute façon il existe des crédits
pour les entreprises pour réduire leur
méthane est ce que ça vient se justifier
massa c'est effrayant comme approche ans
et de se dire j'ai pas besoin
d'intervenir dans ses stratégies de
lutte aux changements climatiques sur
l'un des cols et plus les plus faciles
le volet mettant là c'est à peu près 50%
dans le volet production pétrole et gaz
et c'est sans savoir ce qu'on appelle
des fuites fugitive lancer dans la
production de et dans le transport de
l'ensemble de ses combustibles compères
sa méthode est d'aider ces simples
colmate on peut éviter ces fuites
ça se fait très bien la technologie
existe les coûts sont acceptables et à
un coût qui sont raisonnables dans ses
stratégies de lutte aux changements
climatiques
là on a un modèle où on nous dit j'ai
pas besoin
intervenir sur ce polluant en matière de
grs on entend aussi la même chose au
canada sur qu'est-ce qu'un polluants et
qu'est ce qu'un gaz à effet de serre
alors il faudra être sérieux un jour
pour se dire est ce qu'on veut
effectivement réduire ses émissions de
gaz à effet de serre et on voit très
bien que l'administration autre choix
entre est conforme avec son approche
qu'elle met en place depuis des années
vaste des réglementations et aucun
intérêt pour ces stratégies de lutte aux
changements climatiques c'est désolant
est ce qu'on appelle toujours l' agence
de protection de l'environnement il lui
à 123 milliards de dollars quand même le
gain financier pour le secteur
énergétique d'ici 2025 à ne plus
contrôler on a pu surveiller ces fuites
de méthane et ça c'est intéressant dans
votre analyse parce que là on se dit il
y à un gain financier à ne plus réduire
ses émissions de ges parce que j'ai une
dépense de moins mais en même temps
lorsqu'on fait ces stratégies
réglementaires
on se demande combien coûte cette
modification de comportement du
producteur du consommateur
mais en même temps on se demande quels
sont les gains sociaux pour pouvoir y
arriver
est ce que l'administration ne chôme pas
reculer a défait également c'est le
modèle économique pour mesurer ses coûts
sociaux du carbone alors lorsqu'on a mis
en place cette stratégie avec un
estimation des coûts sociaux à l'époque
de plus de 40 dollars américains la
tonne
c'était rentable de faire ça socialement
parce qu'on avait un coût associé à
cette réduction mais on obtenait 10
gains en matière de réduction des ges
qui se traduisait par des gains
également économique pas seulement
environnementaux
donc c'était rentable et c'est difficile
pour les entreprises entre ça devenait
possible pour les entreprises de
préciser les coûts qui sont associés à
cela des gains sont associés à cela est
ce que c'est pour ça aujourd'hui que les
grandes pétrolières par exemple s'oppose
à la décision de déréglementation de
l'administration trop à ça c'est
intéressant parce que c'est la deuxième
fois qu'on voit ça aussi un peu comme
dans le volet automobile oubliés avec la
californie on s'est dit oh non c'est pas
une bonne approche
donc comment on gère ces grandes
stratégies par une certaine forme de de
cohérent
dans l'action une cohérence de l'état
mais en même temps pour les entreprises
de se dire il faut réduire les
certitudes notamment sur ce prix carbone
et sur ses stratégies de réduction faut
pas jouer au yoyo comme on est fait en
ontario par exemple on en place une
bourse carbone qui est une idée géniale
pour ensuite la retirer on ne sait plus
comment investir et comment travailler
dans ces stratégies donc dans un premier
temps on nous dit c'est pas une bonne
chose parce que le gaz naturel notamment
on le présente comme étant une espèce
d'énergie transition propres si on n'est
pas capable mais plus propre que le
pétrole et le charbon sur l'époque
capable de contrôler ses émissions de
méthane
ça devient de moins en moins vrai et
cette part de marché qu'on veut gagner
sur une énergie plus propre on risque de
ne pas la gagner
l'autre élément intéressant c'est un
espèce de positionnement le plusieurs
entreprises ont annoncé il ya quelques
semaines à peine une vision de ce que
devrait être le rôle d'une entreprise
avec comme scénario il n'y a pas que les
actionnaires qui sont des parties
prenantes dans laquelle il ya un enjeu
fondamental millions aussi un ensemble
d'autres éléments dont des citoyens et
l'environnement
il faut faire attention à mettre en
place les meilleures stratégies
possibles
et parmi les signataires on retrouve
exemple et bp qui viennent nous dire
faut faire attention à notre image
évidemment on fait ça parce qu'on pense
qu'on va gagner en bout de ligne
donc là on à l'administration drame qui
est en train de pas comprendre cet enjeu
là est sûrement faire le jeu des plus
petits producteurs qui eux ne sont pas
capables d'investir adéquatement pour
contrôler ces fuites un moment de
bonheur c'est une perte
un mot en terminant quand on voit ça et
quand on voit aussi le gouvernement
notariaux qui veut aller jusqu'en cour
suprême
et monsieur scheer tantôt le chef de
l'opposition dit la première chose qu'on
va faire si on est élu c'est qu'on va
annuler la taxe carbone est ce que la
taxe carbone est appelée à disparaître
compte tenu du contexte politique est ce
qu'elle devient contre-productive
si on nous si on abolit la stratégie de
tarification du carbone oublié
l'idée d'être efficace au canada en
matière de réduction de gaz à effet de
serre c'est aussi simple que ça même le
directeur parlementaire du budget qui
est un organisme neutre
nous dit la meilleure stratégie pour
réduire les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre en termes économiques la proche la
plus efficiente celle qui nous coûte le
moins cher c'est de mettre un prix sur
le carbone pour amener l'ensemble des
acteurs économiques à faire ces choix là
que nous lisions cette tarification là
ne suscite pas une adhésion complète il
ya des gens qui sont d'accord mais il ya
des gens qui sont contre parce que
malheureusement la vision qu'ont eue en
termes de développement économique
pendant 200 ans dans l'ensemble de
l'occident s'était bonne nouvelle on a
accès à un énergies fossiles à très
faible coût et nous permet de faire des
gains économiques extraordinaires
malheureusement ce n'est pas la fin du
monde
sa question des changements climatiques
mais c'est la fin d'un monde un monde où
l'énergie fossile et est facilement
utilisable ça n'existera plus soit qu'on
continue à faire ça et les conséquences
climatiques sont catastrophiques
soit qu'on réussit d'ici 2050 à faire
cette transition et pour faire ça il
faut gérer le méthane adéquatement
il faut être un prix sur le carbone pour
qu'elle rassemble des acteurs
économiques sur les emporte
économiquement rationnel ma ale webster
merci beaucoup
ce fut un plaisir montrerez